alright one last topic let's talk about
something football related the Cam
Newton contract the detail other's
incentives were reported today by field
gates of espn.com and it is clear based
upon the devices in that contract for
him to make the big money of football
relatively speaking the five point seven
five million in incentives the boxes he
has to check to make all those
incentives and ultimately to make the
full 7.5 million if he does all those
things dresses for every game
participates in 90% or more of the
offensive snaps makes it to the playoffs
makes it to the Pro Bowl becomes The
Associated Press all-pro quarterback
wins the Super Bowl plays at least 50%
of every game long the web doesn't get a
bomb because you need four playoff game
to fifty percent to get the full million
dollar extra incentive at 250,000 a game
I believe or maybe it's five hundred
thousand game regardless we have the
posted PFT that has all the details
everything he has to do to get to 7.5
million basically I win the Superbowl
and he's gonna be the league MVP and if
they win the Superbowl good chance he's
the Super Bowl MVP and the end result is
7.5 million plus the ability of the
Patriots to use the franchise tag on for
2020 in a minute minute the Cam Newton
agent what you say look at least at
least put a clause in here that if he
gets seven million seven a half six and
a half if he fulfills certain number of
these incentives you won't tag him next
year
cuz that's a thing if he has the kind of
year that puts him in line for seven and
a half million he'd be the hottest
commodity ever in free agent you met the
defendant FL MVP Super Bowl champion
likely Super Bowl MVP who's waltzing in
free agency unfettered instead franchise
tag fully available so look if they use
the franchise tag and gets you know 27
28 29 million next year although the
salary cap may screw things up given the
pandemic I'd rather have a shot at the
open mark and it just shows how how
little interest there was
Cam Newton that that offer was put out
there and Cam Newton was willing to take
it because if he does all the things
that get him to seven and a half million
it will be the best return on an
investment for a sports contract in the
history of sports any kind of sport
because the pager is full of bought a
Super Bowl championship for seven and a
half million dollars
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports